très bien mes chers amis chers collègues
chers collègues néanmoins amis ou
l'inverse je sais pas comment dire
nous allons pouvoir commencer cette
audition
sur le PLFSS et nous entendons ce matin
il y a une Gaëlle amgard qui est
directeur de l'URSSAF caisse nationale
que nous avions entendu avant l'été
sur le projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour 2023 j'indique
cette audition fait l'objet d'une
captation vidéo qui sera retransmise en
direct sur le site du Sénat et
disponible en vidéo à la demande et nous
disposons d'une heure avant l'audition
suivante donc monsieur hamgard d'abord
je vous remercie d'avoir décalé
plusieurs fois l'horaire
c'est normal mais c'est quand même
gentil donc je précise et je vous laisse
la parole
merci bien ma Présidente je vous excuser
le caractère assez désagréable pour vous
de ma voix ce matin je vais essayer de
limiter ces agréments mais je crains de
ne pas pouvoir totalement l'éviter ce
sont les problèmes de santé de la saison
de l'automne on l'avait oublié alors
rapidement
propose introductif quelques éléments à
la fois sur
gérer notre activité côté
URSSAF en tant que financeur de la
sécurité sociale et donc sur les
conséquences de l'équilibre financier
sur cette activité et puis par ailleurs
sur quelques articles qui nous
concernent plutôt dans notre activité de
gestionnaire du cotisations sociales
dans le cas du réseau URSSAF
alors
sur l'équilibre financier et l'impact
mission de trésorerie pour l'effet
marquant de l'année 22 et l'année 2023
c'est d'une part la réduction du déficit
du régime général et d'autre part les
reprises de dettes du régime général par
la cadence autour de 40 milliards en
2022 et de 25 milliards 6 en 2023 et
cela se traduit par une réduction forte
des besoins de financement du régime
général on va dire qu'on se rapproche
finalement après la parenthèse de la
crise
deux niveaux de financement plus proche
d'une certaine normalité
c'est normal mais en tout cas c'est
moins exceptionnel que ce qu'on a connu
les dernières années
c'est à dire que pour illustrer
on a un besoin de financement du régime
général qui était à 32 milliards en
début d'année 2022 on finit l'année 2000
on devrait final année 2023 à 13
milliards et si on est strictement sur
le régime général
on n'aurait pas de besoin de financement
à fin d'année 2023
alors on a quand même bien entendu un
plafond d'emprunt proposé dans lequel
effet SS à 45 milliards alors 45
milliards c'est en être très par rapport
à ce qu'il est prévu en 2022 à savoir 65
milliards alors peut-être pour expliquer
ce plafond c'est un maximum autorisé ça
ne veut pas dire bien entendu qu'on
l'utilise et c'est un maximum qui est
calé en tenant compte
d'une part de ce qu'on appelle notre
point bas de trésorerie c'est à dire que
notre profil trésorerie évolue tout au
cours de l'année
on pense qu'on devrait être
à avoir ce point bas en janvier 2023 à
35 milliards
ce point bas il tient compte non
seulement de besoin de financement du
régime général mais aussi du fait que le
côté URSSAF nous effectuons des avances
pour un certain nombre d'autres régimes
c'est à dire que les différents régimes
sociaux qui ont un moment dette une
dette qui n'est pas reprise sur la CADES
nous emprunte
et c'est nous qui allons sur les marchés
financiers
réalisés d'avance à leur place pourquoi
cela
il s'agit d'une logique un petit peu
déficience d'éviter que tous ces régimes
dont certains sont des petits régimes
doivent monter un peu l'ingénierie
financière que suppose le fait d'aller
sur les marchés financiers et ça leur
permet de gérer de bénéficier entre
guillemets de la bonne notation
financière de la cause
aujourd'hui les principaux régimes qui
bénéficient de ces avances de la cause
sont le régime agricole la MSA et la
CNRACL donc la caisse de retraite des
fonctionnaires territoriaux et
hospitaliers
par ailleurs quand on fixe ce plafond on
tient forcément compte d'une part du
fait que on emprunte toujours un peu
plus que ce dont on a besoin pourquoi
parce que nos besoins de financement
varie fortement dans le temps notamment
tous les 10 du mois ou on peut s'en fout
il faut sortir environ 10 milliards pour
les retraites
et qui m'a entendu ce n'est pas le 9
milliards le 9 du moyen du mois qu'on
lève c'est 10 milliards il faut
forcément les lever avec un peu
d'anticipation donc pour être certain de
couvrir cet échéance il a plus
importante c'est du 10 il faut forcément
avoir une marge de prêt emprunt et donc
de sur emprunt ça veut dire qu'on
emprunte forcément plus que le string
nécessaire pour pouvoir être certain de
couvrir tous les échéances car il est
inenvisageable qu'un jour on ne puisse
pas payer les pensions adaptent convenu
alors je vous dis les tensions parce que
c'est la plus forte sortie du mois mais
entendu il y a les sortes les
prestations CAF également en début de
mois et puis il y a les versements au
système de santé tout au long du mois
et puis par ailleurs ce plafond mais il
tient compte inévitablement du fait
qu'on est dans un univers beaucoup plus
incertain que ce qu'on connaissait il y
a encore quelques années et
nécessairement
inévitable indispensable de prévoir dans
le plafond d'emprunt de la cosse des
aléas les aléas
nature économique
qu'il s'agisse de l'impact de la guerre
l'Ukraine de l'impact de l'inflation de
la crise énergétique
ou encore des aléas par exemple sur
l'ONDAM notamment en cas de nouvelles
difficultés sanitaires venant du covid
ou d'autres facteurs je pense que les
années passées les deux trois années
qu'on vient de connaître nous ont montré
qu'il faut intégrer bien plus que
précédemment
cette part d'aléa parce qu'on est rentré
dans un monde plus incertain que ce que
nous connaissions
avant 2020 donc tout cela explique le
fait qu'on a un plafond qui reste à 45
milliards combien même la situation
financière et les besoins de financement
du régime général sont en forte
réduction alors
l'autre changement sur le contexte
d'emprunt c'est que là où nous avons
vécu depuis 2015 dans un univers de taux
négatif
et donc avec une dette du régime général
qui génère des produits financiers
2022 c'est la dernière année on connaît
cela
alors c'est pour du financier ils ont
atteint en 2021 270 millions c'est à
dire que cette dette a rapporté près de
300 millions à la sécurité sociale 2022
on a encore reconnu des taux négatifs
jusqu'à cet été
et depuis le mois de septembre octobre
on rentre dans un univers de taux nul
voir positif et ça va se poursuivre en
2023 donc en 2022 on aura encore pour la
dernière année 60 millions de produits
financiers liés à cette dette mais en
2023 on renoue avec des taux
positifs alors des taux qui restent très
bons parce que on est toujours d'un
contexte
malgré tout de taux qui restent bas qui
reste très inférieure à l'inflation donc
si on raisonne en taux réel on lit
toujours sur des taux réels très
négatifs très défavorable entier mais
voilà c'est quand même un élément un
élément nouveau
qui je souhaite souligner
si je passe maintenant sur les quelques
articles qui concernent
le réseau URSSAF
dans le playst FS
4 articles principalement l'article 5
qui relatif à l'avance immédiate du cri
d'impôt pour la personne alors comme
vous savez depuis
2022 nous avons déployé ce service
d'avance immédiate du climato ça serait
personne qui permet au ménage
utilisateur 6 à la personne de
bénéficier immédiatement de cette grille
d'impôt en fait et de n'avoir à payer
que ce qui reste à la charge du ménage
c'est un système finalement de tiers
payant alors c'est une réforme qui se
met en place graduellement
parce que on a s'agissant des essais à
la personne des activités extrêmement
diverses on peut être en emploi direct
ou passer par un intermédiaire
entreprise de associations mandataire ou
prestataires et puis il y a géré le cas
simple par exemple on a commencé c'est à
dire quand il y a aucune aide sociale
qui intervient mais on sait qu'il y a un
certain nombre de services à la personne
pour lesquels il y a d'autres et qui
interviennent des aides de la CAF
notamment complément mode de garde ou
les aides des départements la paille la
PCH donc on a commencé par le calcul
simple c'est-à-dire la situation où il
n'y a pas d'autres
il y a pas d'aide sociale on a
aujourd'hui 300 000 ménages qui ont
activé ce service
la cible est bien que l'ensemble des
ménages en bénéficient cela suppose des
travaux avec la CAF avec les
départements pour intégrer les
prestations en question dans le circuit
et donc le l'article 5 qui faisait
proposer
portent sur le calendrier en fait de
mise en oeuvre de cette réforme mais la
cible est bien que l'ensemble des
ménages puissent en bénéficier en 2024
on a un article 6 qui comporte diverses
dispositions sur le contrôle avec l'idée
d'une généraliser une exportation sur la
durée des contrôles pour les très
petites entreprises
qui perdent cet article permet aussi de
définir comment en cas dans la situation
notamment de contrôle ou l'entreprise ne
corrige pas d'elle-même ses données
sociales l'URSSAF ou la MSA peut
corriger à sa place les données sociales
et permettre qu'elle soit utilisée par
les organismes qui versent les
prestations notamment la caisse de
retraite
l'article 9 nous concerne au titre
du simplifié pour les médecins qui
exerce une activité libérale réduite
c'est un dispositif qui a été introduit
il y a maintenant trois ans qui permet à
des médecins une activité libérale
réduite de d'avoir géré un mode très
simplifié de gestion des cotisations
sociales pour ne pas avoir tout la
charge administrative que représente les
Coutances sociales classiques donc on a
discutif simplifié et qui est étendu par
ce projet d'article aux activités de
régulation on pourrait revenir si vous
le souhaitez et donc par ailleurs donc
l'article 41 comporte plusieurs
dispositions qui visent à la faciliter à
la fois nos actions de lutte contre la
fraude et également de recouvrement des
créances frauduleuses je vous remercie
de votre attention
très bien
merci Monsieur le Directeur et je vais
passer tout de suite la parole à
elisabethoanno rapporteur général on
n'est pas le Savary président de La
Mecque et Katia pour ce poly merci
madame la Présidente merci Monsieur le
Directeur j'aimerais tout d'abord faire
un petit retour en arrière si je peux me
permettre sur le refus de certification
des comptes 2021 de la branche
recouvrement par la Cour des comptes
dans ce rapport sur l'application de la
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale la Cour a de nouveau en fait
souligné et nous la redit la semaine
dernière que les modalités de
comptabilisation des cotisations et
contributions sociales des travailleurs
indépendants conduisent à ne pas donner
une image fidèle du déficit du régime
général en 2021 et de son évolution donc
entre 2020 et 2021 et le premier
président
la effectivement exprimée devant nous
lors de son audition la semaine dernière
et dès lors il est pas vraiment possible
pour votre organisme de manière générale
pour la sécurité sociale de présenter
les comptes de l'année 2021 de manière à
respecter les recommandations de
l'acompte bref est-ce que vous pouvez
revenir un peu en arrière et reprendre
les recommandations de la Cour
ma deuxième question est sur la marge
d'autorisation d'emprunt vous l'avez
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
exposé l'emprunt à court terme de 45
milliards d'euros en 2023 Lestelle à la
caisse j'aimerais avoir plus
d'explications finalement que ce que
vous avez donné tout à l'heure au regard
des transferts de la cadèse qui reste à
faire et pourriez-vous préciser en fait
cette chronique prévue de ces transferts
à la Cadès l'année prochaine est-ce que
il satureront l'enveloppe de 136
milliards d'euros accordés par le
Parlement en 2020
la dernière question c'est sur la
sensibilité de l'URSSAF caisse nationale
aux conditions d'emprunt sur le marché
pouvez-vous ressentir dès à présent une
tension sur la disponibilité des fonds
vous avez de dire enfin c'est ce que je
viens d'entendre que finalement les
choses se passaient plutôt bien mais en
réalité est-ce que aujourd'hui dans les
incertitudes que traverse notre pays
comme je dirais le monde est-ce qu'on
peut vraiment avoir cette capacité à
penser que les choses iront bien demain
étant donné l'inflation et le coût des
emprunts merci
prenez Paul Savary on va prendre
plusieurs questions oui merci
merci madame la Présidente bien sûr on
parle du du transfert du recouvrement de
l'argile Carco pour lequel on a déjà eu
l'occasion de de discuter
l'Assemblée nationale à la commission
des affaires sociales ils ont supprimé
ce transfert de façon définitive
nous n'en étions pas arrivé à ce
point-là
il n'empêche que il y a encore un
certain nombre de problèmes à régler
semble-t-il puisque il était proposé de
le faire en deux fois une fois pour les
grosses entreprises dans un premier
temps avant de passer à l'ensemble des
entreprises et je ne suis pas convaincu
que les éditeurs de logiciels sont
entièrement au point en tout cas hier
dans l'audition que nous avons eu avec
Elisabeth Doisneau on voyait bien qu'il
avait encore un certain nombre de
difficultés
il est peut-être important d'attendre un
peu par rapport à cette fiabilisation la
Cour des comptes nous l'avait dit est-ce
que vous restez toujours sur la même
position
ou pas en ce qui concerne également le
transfert de la Caisse des Dépôts la
Caisse des dépôts qui s'occupe du
recouvrement des cotisations pour la
CNRAC notamment ou pour lire canta ou la
raft
semble dire qu'elle ne voit pas
d'intérêt non plus là aussi à continuer
cette volonté de
d'universalisation des recouvrements des
prestations sociales sachant que c'est
pas une université puisque il y a un
certain nombre d'organismes qui seront
pas concernés on pense notamment à la
MSA alors est-ce que vous la volonté de
continuer toujours sur cette voie là ou
bien on pose un peu on se pose un peu en
attendant d'avoir un certain nombre de
précisions puis un deuxième une
troisième question sur les cultes on
voit qu'il y a un certain nombre de
difficultés on les avait levées
est-ce que là aussi quel est votre point
de vue pour essayer de trouver de
trouver un terrain d'entente avec ces
différents organismes de façon à ce que
c'est recouvrements s'il s'envisage ne
soit pas subi mais partagez dans la
philosophie de de recouvrement
si tenter qu'il y en ait une
vous répondez peut-être déjà et puis
ensuite on passera aux questions des
collègues très volonté
par Madame l'arbre en général alors
concernant le refus de certification par
la Cour des comptes alors tout d'abord
je voudrais bien expliciter le terrain
sur lequel s'est porté le débat alors on
n'est pas sur une remise en cause soit
de la fiabilité des comptes ou du
contrôle interne
on est sur un débat portant sur
l'application des normes comptables et
l'appréciation
de deux éléments de deux événements au
regard des normes comptables
et notamment le débat est de savoir
comment à quel exercice
on rattache
deux épisodes
premier point
qui était déjà les deux sujets étaient
déjà présents dans le débat avec la cour
la situation des Comptes 2020 le premier
sujet porte sur les régularisations de
cotisations des travailleurs
indépendants sur les revenus 2020
comme vous le savez les travailleurs
indépendants sont sur un système de
cotisation provisionnelle provisoire
c'est la base de dernier revenu connu et
avec une régularisation qui intervient
l'année suivante lorsque leur revenu
définitif est connu et déclaré
en 2020 dans le contexte de crise
sanitaire et pareil en anticipation
d'une forte baisse indépendants nous
avions réduit d'office les prélèvements
sur les travailleurs indépendants ça a
donné lieu à une régularisation
intervenue en 2021
nous avons appliqué
sur ce sujet
à la fois les normes comptables
qui dit précisent très clairement que
pour les cotisations travailleurs
indépendantes on rattache à un exercice
donné les cotisations appelées sur cet
exercice et que la régularisation qui a
lieu à une plus un et rattachée à
l'exercice suivant c'est ce que décrit
très précisément les normes comptables
qui s'appliquent aux organismes sociales
telles qu'elles sont définies par le
conseil de normalisation des comptes
publics
les normes comptables qui sont écrites
qui sont extrêmement précises et
prescriptives sur ce point et c'est
d'ailleurs la norme comptable que nous
avons appliqué de manière permanente
depuis que nous traçons les comptes des
cotisations et depuis qu'il y a
l'application des droits constatés
sociales donc nous avons fait
qu'appliquer les mêmes méthodes que ce
que nous avons fait chaque année
et donc ce que nous avons fait gérer
dans la stricte orthodoxie l'application
des normes comptables l'autre point de
discussion avec la Cour des comptes
porte sur l'évaluation du risque de non
recouvrement
sur les dettes accumulées par les
entreprises en 2020 dans le contexte de
report massif consenti par les urssafs
pour la crise sanitaire
dans les comptes 2020 donc établi au
cours du premier trimestre 2021
nous avions fait une évaluation
de ce risque de nous recouvrement alors
on avait fait une évaluation un peu
Haddock considérant qu'on ne pouvait pas
prendre les références historiques du
fait du caractère très particulier très
émotionnel de ces dettes covid
accumulées par des entreprises en 2020
nous avions calés cette méthode
d'ailleurs en accord avec la Cour des
comptes la Cour des comptes validé le
fait qu'on établisse une méthode
particulière et n'avait pas contesté nos
hypothèses conseillé qu'il y avait
certaines incertitudes sur ces
hypothèses mais elle n'est pas contestée
ce principe
dans l'établissement des comptes 2021 on
a dû réévaluer ce risque de
non-recouvrement
et on a constaté que finalement c'est
d'être covid accumuler par les
entreprises en 2020
a été remboursé par les entreprises
beaucoup plus facilement et rapidement
que ce qu'on espérait début 2021
et donc celle de conduisait à
révaluer notre estimation de notre
espoir de recouvrement de ces créances
2020 et donc cela nous a conduit à
corriger cette estimation là aussi et
non comptable sont extrêmement précises
lorsqu'on corrige une estimation sur la
base d'éléments d'information de
nouvelles cette correction et rattachée
à l'exercice au cours duquel on effectue
cette évaluation d'estimation donc
l'exercice 2021
on le fait sur ce point qui appliquer
les normes comptables la Cour des
comptes aurait voulu
que sur ces deux points on crée des
comptes un peu proforma pour traiter ces
deux événements en dehors des comptes de
l'exercice 2021
ce n'est pas conforme on en compte et
dans le comptable ne prévoit pas cela
donc moi je ne peux pas rectifier les
comptes et clairement je suis désolé de
dire ainsi mais ce que la Cour attendait
de nous
reconduit je trouve à une forme un peu
de bricolage sur les manières de
présenter les comptes
et donc nous l'avons fait qu'appliquer
ces comptes et d'ailleurs nous avons
aussi une logique parce que nous
collectons pour des organismes qui ne
sont pas
dans le choix social par exemple pour
luidic donc l'unique dans ces camps 2021
a été certifié sans réserve
ceux qui montrent que les commissaires
aux comptes de lunédique ont suivi le
même raisonnement que nous donc
aujourd'hui si on se mettait à suivre
les recommandations de la Cour des
comptes en plus on aurait des choix
comptables qui seraient pas cohérents
entre ce qui s'applique au régime
général et ce que les commissaires aux
comptes et donc les organismes
ont retenu donc voilà ça explique qu'on
ne peut pas retenir cette approche après
si on se tourne vers l'avenir la Cour
des comptes allume reconnaît que ces
divergences d'appréciations sont tout à
fait exceptionnels et liés au contexte à
partir de la crise covid ça n'a pas
vocation à se répéter puisque c'est
comme vraiment lié à deux sujets qui
sont tout à fait liés aux circonstances
2020 21
alors concernant votre deuxième question
madame laboratoire général sur la
l'autorisation d'emprunt oui nos
considérons que cette cette marge est
suffisante
manière classique d'ailleurs ce plafond
et proposer par le gouvernement dans le
cadre des changes avec la cause sur
notre
prévision de profil de risque de profil
de trésorerie
en tenant compte par ailleurs
effectivement de l'ensemble des
événements il s'agisse du des besoins de
financement du régime général mais aussi
des reprises de l'Académie donc nous
avons intégré dans cette prévision de
trésorerie à la fois les reprises qui
ont lieu en 2022 à savoir les 40
milliards et les 25 milliards 6 qui sont
prévus en 2023 alors
encore une fois je l'ai dit il y a
plusieurs éléments qui permettent
d'arriver à ce 45 milliards il y a le
point bas du régime général il y a par
ailleurs la prise en compte des avances
ou régime partenaires à hauteur de 5
milliards et il y a le fait
que l'on nous procédons à cette forme de
sur empreinte pré-emprunt à une hauteur
qui peut atteindre 15 milliards et ce
qui d'ailleurs répond à vous tenir
question qui est extrêmement pertinente
des prégnante en ce moment celle des
conditions d'accès au marché financier
et là aussi Jacques en 2020 on a changé
de monde jusque là
en 2020 on était sur une politique de
minimisation de notre sol sur le compte
c'est à dire qu'on empruntait
ou un peu au jour le jour et au strict
nécessaire
ça renvoyait aussi à une logique qui
était dans les époques où les taux
d'intérêt étaient élevés qui était une
logique de réduire le coût de
financement du régime général et donc on
essayait de réduire au minimum
[Musique]
l'autre emprunt et de le caler au plus
près du profil trésorerie et en se
disant qu'on n'avait pas de difficultés
à lever les fonds sur les marchés donc
c'était une politique jusqu'au 2020 qui
était très dicté par la logique du coup
et donc de réduction du besoin de
financement
2020 avec notamment la deuxième moitié
de mois de mars 2020 où les marchés
étaient complètement fermés en pratique
c'est à dire on pouvait
pas fermé au régime général en
particulier c'est fermé tout court pour
l'ensemble des émetteurs privés comme
public et donc pour vous dire ce qui est
assez en mars 2020 là où une journée
moyenne on place de milliards sur les
marchés ont placé parfois 100 millions
200 millions donc clairement on était en
grande tension de financement sur les
marchés et voilà on sait que
l'exercice de nous a permis de couvrir
les prestations de début avril 2020 a
été extrêmement tendu et qu'on a dû
solliciter toute une série de concours
notamment le concours de la Caisse des
Dépôts
et donc ça nous a conduit à changer
effectivement notre politique de
financement et aujourd'hui avoir une
culture de financement qui est blouse
beaucoup plus tournée vers la
sécurisation
des échéances de paiement les
prestations et donc là où avant on était
très focalisé sur la question du coup de
la dette maintenant on est beaucoup plus
utilisé la question du risque de
liquidité alors
si je mets de côté la période de mars
2020 globalement on a un bon accès au
marché financier voilà on bénéficie de
la bonne notation de la dette française
on a d'ailleurs voilà on a de très
bonnes notes de la part des agences de
notation
mais
on est comme on est un émetteur
uniquement à court terme c'est à dire
qu'on n'avons pas le droit d'avoir des
titres qui dépassent 360 jours
ça veut dire que ça nous contraint à
renouveler en permanence notre dette
c'est-à-dire que chaque jour nous devons
renouveler une partie importante de nos
emprunts pour ne serait-ce que maintenir
notre niveau de financement donc ça veut
dire que nous devons aller tous les
jours sur les marchés on n'est pas comme
certains émetteurs publics et comme
l'after qui font des aides éducations
tous les tous les mois ou tous les deux
mois nous on doit y aller tous les jours
et donc ça veut dire qu'on est plus
exposé
au risque de période de d'incertitude
fin d'incertitude sur le marché
financier ou de choc exogène et pour
vous administration ces derniers mois on
se financer bien par contre on est dans
un contexte
deuxième trimestre et cet été ou les
investisseurs attendaient des décisions
des banques centrales sur les taux
d'intérêt et d'ailleurs ces décisions
sont intervenues
et ça s'est traduit par un fort
attentisme nous investisseurs c'est à
dire qu'il voulait bien le prêter mais
pas au-delà d'un mois et donc ça rendait
l'exercice
beaucoup plus compliqué on y arrive à
chaque fois mais ça veut dire que ça
plaide là aussi pour rester sur cette
politique de prudence et qui veut dire
que là où avant la crise sanitaire
on cherchait à couvrir les 7 à 10 jours
qui venaient devant nous
il y a des gens qui venaient on allait
pouvoir trouver les ressources là notre
cible est de couvrir au moins un mois
devant nous parce que on veut se couvrir
contre
des aléas de nature soit géopolitiques
soit financière qui a un moment ferait
qu'on aurait une période plus difficile
sur les marchés financiers donc
aujourd'hui pour vous répondre de
manière plus adhétique on a un bon accès
marché financier mais on est en tant
qu'il metteur à court terme exposé à des
périodes qui sont forcément bornés dans
le temps mais t'es perdues financiers
peuvent être plus nerveux plus
attentiste et donc ça plaît pour avoir
une politique de prudence qui se traduit
par aussi ce plafond d'emprunt qui est
fixé avec un une marge considérable
je vais venir maintenant aux questions
posées par Monsieur le Président de la
Mecque alors concernant le transfert du
recouvrement retraite complémentaire
tout d'abord donc effectivement ce que
le gouvernement a annoncé et qui devrait
se traduire dans un décret prochainement
c'est un transfert en deux temps en
commençant par les grandes entreprises
pour faire simple donc environ 9000
entreprises
on va en 2023 et avec une génération en
2024 alors encore une fois nous on
considère que opérationnellement nous
sommes prêts pour cette réforme que
d'une part le pilote réalisé que
l'éditeur qui a permis de tester
l'ensemble des cas réglementaires qui
avaient des comblé avec la Girard Carco
a permis de voir que les différentes
fonctionnalités évolution était possible
je rappelle que ce pilote a mobilise
éditeur qui représente 90% de la paye
dans le pays donc on est quand même un
pilote qui est assez couvrant et par
ailleurs les trois quatre mois qui sont
devant nous vont être mis à profit pour
embarquer dans un groupe d'entreprises
volontaires supplémentaires dans ce
pilote
sur la question souvent mise en avant
par la jrco à savoir celle de la
fiabilisation des droits pour la recette
complémentaires
je redis ce qu'on avait plusieurs fois
l'agirco va continuer à avoir les mêmes
actions que celle que là aujourd'hui à
la fois sur le contrôle des données
retraitée et sur la gestion après du
compte individuel donc il n'y a pas de
risque de régression là-dessus et
d'ailleurs non des documents de légèreté
on voit bien qu'elle considère qu'il y a
que le risque de régression sur ce sujet
là est faible
par ailleurs le fait de commencer par
les grandes entreprises permet aussi de
sécuriser
la réforme dans la mesure où ces
entreprises d'une part sont quand même
plus
armés pour mettre en place ce changement
arriver qui a lieu dans quelques mois et
par ailleurs ces grandes entreprises
ont bénéficie au sein légère Carco comme
de l'URSSAF dater personnalisé qui
seront même de les accompagner dans
cette transition alors effectivement
nous-même nous avons des échanges
quotidiens en ce moment avec les
éditeurs de paix pour déterminer comment
un éditeur gérera le fait d'avoir
potentiellement des clients qui sont
pour les uns dans le transfert de
recouvrement et les autres non alors
c'est c'est pas ingérable c'est pas dire
la première fois qu'une réforme se
déploie progressivement et notamment par
pallier de taille d'entreprises donc on
est en train de voir les éditeurs pour
sécuriser ce point mais c'est un sujet
qui est à la fois une par identifié et
qui le point de vue n'est pas n'est pas
à son montage
alors concernant le transfert à la
caisse d'EP dépôt et des collègues de
Caisse des Dépôts quotidien et
consignation donc c'est une race elle
etc alors bon le chantier est nettement
moins avancé et il conviendra de
d'examiner dans quelle mesure le nouveau
calendrier
concernant la vraie complémentaire
agirco a des conséquences sur sur ce
calendrier
concernant la caisse des cultes là pour
le coup on a toujours des travaux en
cours avec eux mais je crois dans une
philosophie une forme tout fait partager
visant bien à dans une coopération avec
eux et notamment à les laisser
positionner sur les éléments sur
lesquels
l'URSSAF d'ailleurs n'a pas intérêt à
rentrer qui est notamment la compétence
pour déterminer
une activité culte ou non ce qui est un
sujet sur lequel je me garderai bien de
rentrer un jour
voilà donc voilà je pense c'est un sujet
qui doit pouvoir trouver une franchement
une solution tout à fait apaisée en tout
cas les discussions sont en cours sont
pour avoir une convention qui termine
comment on travaille avec la canicule
alors
au total voilà je pense qu'on a des
chantiers qui peuvent se poursuivre
qui encore une fois son porteur de
simplification et par ailleurs de gains
en performance de recouvrement et du
contrôle
et alors on n'est pas dans une logique
d'universalisation mais pour je prends
une raison qui a été assez bien
expliquée dès la FS pour 2020
l'idée c'est
d'offrir aux différents
cotisants avec du cynique pour leur
cotisations sociales vous avez mentionné
quel régime agricole le régime la MSA
offre déjà celui-ci unique pour le
régime agricole pour les couturiers
agricoles donc il n'y aurait pas de
gains pour les cotisants de l'école à
rentrer dans le monde URSSAF à la
différence des cotisants agir Carco ou
CDC qui connaissent à la fois l'URSSAF
et d'autres collecteurs voilà donc le
fait qu'ils ne sont pas sur logique
totalement universelle
de cette réforme
oui Monsieur le Directeur merci j'ai
entendu vos arguments mais donc ça a été
dit par notre collègue René Paul le
PLFSS 2023 donc prévoit l'article 6 le
transfert donc précipité à mon sens du
recouvrement des cotisations à giracco
vers l'URSSAF
nous avions travaillé un rapport avec
notre collègue René Paul Savary et je
pense que une fois de plus le
gouvernement n'a pas entendu et n'a pas
écouté les préconisations du Sénat et je
le regrette pour ma part et pour rappel
quand même
l'ensemble des organisations et
syndicales et patronales et patronales
sont opposés à l'unification du
recouvrement des cotisations des régimes
complémentaires de retraite
alors nous ne disions pas dans ce
rapport et ça a été rappelé à juste
titre qu'il ne fallait pas le faire nous
demandions aider les supplémentaires une
vision pas c'était pas un blackout
c'était nous demandions un délai
supplémentaire et donc je voudrais vous
poser une question parce que je rappelle
que le transfert du recouvrement des
cotisations
agir Carco 1er janvier 2023 donc des
entreprises soumises au dispositif du
versement lieu unique
c'est 9170 entreprises
soit 5,6 millions de salariés et au 1er
janvier 2024 donc ça se mettrait en
place pour les autres quelle garantie
supplémentaire
apportez vous au gouvernement pour
justifier de l'unification précipitée du
recouvrement des cotisations des régimes
complémentaires de retraite à l'URSSAF
je vous remercie parce que on parle ici
évidemment pour les assurer d'une perte
de contrôle
sur leurs droits individuels je vous
remercie Olivier Hainaut
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le directeur pour vos propos et
pour cette clarté sur une matière
complexe mais indispensable qui est la
question du financement de notre
protection sociale lorsque ça s'appelait
encore la cause vous aviez ici lors
d'une audition évoquée avec les taux
d'intérêt négatifs des provisions
positives et j'avais été assez marqué
par par ça parce que c'était
culturellement pas habituel d'imaginer
ça évidemment du fait de de l'inflation
peut-être du ralentissement de
l'activité
les taux d'intérêt vont monter et donc
est-ce que vous avez une évaluation de
l'évolution de ces provisions maintenant
que les taux d'intérêt vous l'avez déjà
abordé mais est-ce que vous avez une
est-ce que vous abordez ça dans une
perspective de ce que pourrait
représenter la charge de la dette
à courir moyen terme pour pour la caisse
ça c'est une question de portée générale
et puis maintenant une question qui
concerne la branche famille qui est
assez technique vous l'avez commencé à
l'aborder mais le PLFSS prévoit une
réforme du calcul du CMG on peut directe
compensant une partie de la rémunération
de l'assistante maternelle ou de
l'employé à domicile pour garde
d'enfants la prestation est versée
financée par la branche famille mais
fait l'objet depuis 2019 du
dintermédiation par le dispositif page
emploi on l'a déjà abordé aussi ici
cette perspective rattachée à l'URSSAF
et dans quelle mesure ce circuit
d'intermédiation par Pajemploi sera-t-il
concerné par ce changement de calcul du
CMG l'entrée en vigueur de la réforme
est prévue pour 2025 certaines
difficultés techniques vous les aviez
déjà abordés que pourraient rencontrer
pas Jean-Paul doivent-elles être levées
dans ce délai comment elles vont l'être
et pouvez-vous nous éclairer sur
l'articulation sur le système d'avance
immédiate des aides fiscales pour garde
d'enfants notamment prévu dans le
dernier la dernière loi de finance de la
sécurité sociale pour une mise en œuvre
à l'horizon 2024 et notamment cette
réforme du CMG je vous remercie
oui merci ma Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur oui moi je voulais revenir
aussi sur cette article 5 sur
l'échéancier là pour les avances
comme c'est un article spécifique est-ce
que le calendrier a été modifié parce
qu'on avait un calendrier dans le PLFSS
qui était
que nous avions voté alors c'est un à
vrai dire je ne sais pas c'est une
question que je vous pose parce que vous
comprenez bien que quand même ça pose un
problème comment dirais-je
davantage concurrentiel quand même
pour les associations prestataires
notamment s'il passe derrière le
mandataire s'il y a pas derrière le gré
à gré un crédit d'impôt en direct un
impact quand même très important sur le
recours pour beaucoup de familles donc
j'espère au moins que déjà
il y avait un calendrier dont on pouvait
émettre une certaine critique
notamment pour les
le nom du créatif prestataire j'espère
qu'il a pas été reculé et alors ma
deuxième question recoupe celle de mon
collègue enfin j'aurais aimé savoir au
moins depuis 2015 puisque vous avez dit
que depuis 2015 les taux négatifs donc
produisait générer des produits
financiers le cumul vous nous avez donné
270 millions une estimation de 60
millions pour cette année mais est-ce
qu'on a alors je savais pas qu'il y
avait des provisions positives mais si
c'est là qu'on les met au moins le cumul
depuis 2015 de ces produits financiers
qui peuvent effectivement
permettre de faire face à des taux
d'intérêt qui peuvent être à l'inverse
un coup financier pour la caisse
[Musique]
dans l'application aujourd'hui
l'exonération s'applique à tous les
salaires et les salariés titulaires d'un
contrat de travail de droit privé ou
public et quel que soit la forme et la
durée de du contrat de travail et il
s'avère que à première vue dans
l'application les fonctionnaires sont
exclus de du sujet donc seuls les
contrats de droit public le sont intégré
donc j'aurais voulu avoir de précision
sur un point qui semble relativement
important donc sur toutes les zones et
d'erreurs de France qui sont concernées
alors Daniel Jassin ensuite victoire
jasmin et Jean-Marie merci madame la
Présidente merci Monsieur le Directeur
donc une première question
qui a déjà été posée si vous voulez
depuis
2015 donc vous avez des empereurs qui
rapportent même 60 millions d'euros en
2020 vous avez indiqué et depuis octobre
2022 les taux deviennent positifs avec
des difficultés à savoir à quel taux
vous allez emprunter puisque vous avez
parlé de d'un attentisme des prêteurs et
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire pour
quel taux vous avez anticipé ou si vous
ne l'avez pas fait mais quel taux on
peut anticiper pour l'année 2023 et les
années futures et deuxièmement une
question
assez technique concernant les médecins
vous savez que beaucoup de cabinets
fonctionne avec des médecins retraités
et actuellement
certains médecins ne veulent plus
cotiser ne veulent plus faire de
remplacement parce que il cotise à la
campagne mais si vous voulez hypotisent
à fond perdu et certains m'ont indiqué
que pour un petit chiffre d'affaires on
pouvait seulement cotiser à l'URSSAF et
je voulais avoir des précisions à ce
niveau là et pour quel chiffre
d'affaires et
quelles cotisations sociales puisque ça
s'est demandé par les médecins retraités
merci
victoire jasmin
merci madame la Présidente oui moi je
voudrais savoir quels sont vos m'écoutez
voilà merci oui je voudrais savoir
quelles sont les mesures qui ont été
prises concernant les incompatibilités
des systèmes de formation qui ont existé
et qui existent probablement encore et
qui ont été préjudiciables à la plupart
des acteurs notamment les travailleurs
indépendants avec les problèmes de URSS
notamment donc quelles sont les mesures
qui ont été prises et est-ce que ça ne
contribue pas également à
partir de ces éléments là d'avoir des
incohérences concernant tout ce que vous
pourriez aussi
appelé des détournements ou en tout cas
je sais pas trop comment dire mais des
personnes qui pourraient avoir cotisé
mais contenu de ces situations là pour
apparaître comme étant les personnes qui
seraient pas en conformité
très bien et pour terminer Jean-Marie
Valin merci Madame ma présidente ma
question sera brève Monsieur le
Directeur ça concerne les fraudes je
voulais savoir où vous en étiez de
l'estimation
de du montant de la fraude et des moyens
effectivement que vous entendiez mettre
en œuvre pour la contrôler la réprimer
merci beaucoup et Annick
oui merci
présidente voilà Monsieur le Directeur
je profite en fait de votre venue pour
vous poser une petite question je sais
pas si je suis hors sujet ou pas mais
voilà j'étais ce matin justement avant
de venir en visioconférence avec notre
présidente de région qui entre autres
nous a parlé d'un
ticket mobilité qu'elle souhaitait
mettre en place donc sur la région de
Bourgogne Franche-Comté qui consisterait
à louer un chèque mensuel de 40 euros à
tous les salariés qui toucheraient
jusqu'à deux fois le SMIC pour les aider
en ces périodes difficiles où l'énergie
est si cher je rappelle que la Bourgogne
Franche-Comté comme beaucoup de régions
et une zone en partie rurale et puis que
pour les salariés qui ont à se déplacer
la voiture est indispensable alors la
région prendrait en charge 20 euros les
entreprises prendraient en charge 20
euros sur 11 mois de l'année et
le problème c'est que les entreprises
enfin pour l'URSSAF ça devient un
avantage en nature qui donc est soumis à
charge sociale donc ça rend chéri
d'autant le coup pour les entreprises
qui veulent bien faire un effort mais
voilà alors qu'est-ce qui aurait une
solution ou comment est-ce que ce
dossier pourrait être traité pour qu'il
y ait pas un coup trop important pour
les entreprises c'est un une idée que je
trouve bonne et qui pourrait
éventuellement se dupliquer sur d'autres
régions donc voilà je voulais votre
sentiment par rapport à ça merci bien
merci alors Monsieur le Directeur
beaucoup de questions
merci de la présidente alors tout
d'abord pour revenir sur les questions
soulevées par Madame la scatterie ça
pour ce poly concernant le transfert
agirco
je pense que
c'est un projet sur lequel on travaille
depuis 3 ans avec la jrco donc on peut
pas parler de précipitation le
gouvernement par ailleurs
étalent en deux phases en commençant par
les grandes entreprises mais donc quand
même par 9000 entreprises sur le million
cinq d'entreprises du pays donc je pense
ça tient compte de la demande de
progressivité de sécurisation que vous
aviez exprimé vous avez mentionné la
prise de position des partenaires
sociaux
c'est une prise de position qui renvoie
à des arguments et à des craintes de
nature plus politiques tenant à la
question de la fusion des régimes de la
question des réserves alors point sur
lequel le gouvernement a donné des
engagements est très franchement on sait
très bien que il n'y a pas de lien entre
le fait que on collecte ou non une
ressource et la capacité du gouvernement
a fusionner ou non un régime ou à
ponctionner des réserves sont des sujets
de nature différents après voilà il y a
une inquiétude des partenaires sociaux
elle est nature politique mais ça ne
porte pas sur
Non mais quand j'essayais pas de
jugement sur le fait que les partenaires
ce que je vous dis c'est que il y a deux
manières d'aborder ce sujet du transfert
de recouvrement
soit on regarde sur la question
Quels sont les risques opérationnels
pour les entreprises pour les salariés
etc
voilà sur ce point nous avons depuis le
début des nations de garantie et
notamment la question des droits des
salariés madame matrice encore une fois
l'agircarco continuera à faire ce
qu'elle fait aujourd'hui donc il n'y a
pas de risque de régression sur la
gestion des droits des salariés et la
Gère Carco elle-même le reconnaît dans
des documents internes c'est-à-dire
karko elle-même écrit que le risque de
moindre fiabilité des droits à retraite
complémentaire est faible
donc voilà ce sujet là je pense je
comprends que il y a une inquiétude sur
ce risque mais je peux vous donner des
garanties sur le fait que dès lors que
les gens continuera à faire quelques
jours il n'y a pas de risque de
régression dans le cadre de ce projet on
travaille avec la gercarco et
le ministère de tutelle à faire une
analyse des risques parce que voilà
comme on le fait pour tout projet de
cette nature
mais il n'y a pas de risque par exemple
de perte de contrôle sur les droits des
salariés et donc on met à profit les
mois qui viennent pour sécuriser et bien
entendu
vous ne manquerez pas et c'est normal de
vous demander de rendre des comptes y
compris sur le premier jalon bien
entendu c'est c'est tout à fait normal
qu'on doit vendre des comptes sur cette
première étape
alors sur la question
soulevée à la fois par Monsieur sénateur
et nous madame la senatrice pensait
Monge et monsieur le sénateur Chassin
sur la question des produits financiers
et notre prévision des du coup charge
d'intérêt alors tout d'abord avoir
peut-être que les produits financiers
qu'on avait cette année ils n'ont pas
constitué une cagnotte c'est à dire
qu'ils sont venus ils étaient intégrés
je dirais au solde de l'inscription
sociale et donc ça venait réduire un peu
le déficit du régime général alors
malheureusement je n'ai pas fait
l'exercice de d'addition comme vous
m'avez
que vous demandez de faire je pourrais
le faire postérieurement à l'audition si
vous souhaitez vous le transmettre
ouais je pense qu'on doit être
de l'ordre du milliard puisque encore
une fois je redonne les chiffres cette
année on sera 60 millions l'an dernier
on était à 27 milliards et on va dire
que les années entre 2016
oui excusez-moi donc 60 millions 270
millions l'an dernier et on a eu toute
une série d'années on était entre 100 et
150 donc je pense que comme en gros
santons de 2015 2022 ça devrait être de
l'ordre du milliard mais je pourrais
vous donner quelque chose de beaucoup
plus précis bien entendu alors après
non de produits financiers cumulé
pendant toute la période où nous étions
en taux négatif après encore une fois
comme j'ai dit ça n'est pas constitué un
fond de réserve ça évite venu réduire
les déficits voilà vous l'avez bien en
tête alors sur l'année 2023
[Musique]
on prévoit que le besoin le besoin de
financement moyen sur l'année du régime
général sera de 18 milliards
donc alors on peut faire une estimation
en disant en supposant par exemple qu'on
est 0,5 % de taux d'intérêt moyen sur
l'année ça ferait un coup de l'ordre de
pas me tromper
de l'ordre de 90 millions donc de
l'ordre de 100 millions donc voilà on
pense que si on est sur un demi point de
taux d'intérêt moyen on se rase de
l'ordre de 100 millions et voilà vous
pouvez faire l'exercice
en passant sur une place à 1% etc etc
voilà tout en rappelant encore une fois
que
c'est l'inflation et donc en réel ça
reste ça reste négatif
pour venir maintenant à la question
posée parmi ces interrenault sur
Pajemploi et le CMG et l'avance
immédiate alors oui effectivement dès
lors que ces Pajemploi qui aujourd'hui
gère entre guillemets le complément mode
de garde
lorsqu'on est en emploi direct
effectivement c'est nous qui allons
devoir mettre en œuvre cette réforme et
d'ailleurs ça explique le calendrier
retenu au vu des difficultés que vous
avez rappelé c'est à dire que on sait
qu'on a eu un certain nombre de
difficultés en 2018 19 dans le cadre de
la mise en œuvre de la réforme du
couplement mode de garde
et ça révélé une certaine obsolescence
en fait du système d'information de
pages emploi donc nous avons lancé un
programme de rénovation complète de ce
système d'information de page emploi et
c'est une fois que cette rénova
rénovation aura été mise en œuvre en
2024 que nous pourrons réaliser tous les
évolutions prévues sur le complément de
mode de garde qui sont comme des
évolutions très structurantes sur la
manière de calculer cette prestation
donc cela explique le calendrier retenu
en 2025 vous avez posé la question de
l'articulation avec l'avance immédiate
du canapé service à la personne donc
cette avance bien personne sera
accessible au minage qui bénéficient du
complément de mode de garde en 2024
alors très concrètement
aujourd'hui le ménage
paye
la Suisse en maternelle elle regarde
d'enfants ce qui reste à sa charge après
complément mode de garde
et
dans le dispositif c'est qu'ils se
mettra en place en 2024
il ne paiera plus que ce charge après le
comblement de garde et crédit d'impôts
donc ça réduira l'avance de frais que le
ménage doit réaliser
on est sur un système
qui était compliqué métronome et qui
tient du point de vue de l'usager et
extrêmement simple en fait c'est à dire
encore une fois je pense vous pouvez
faire l'expérience sur les 300 000
ménages j'en suis qui ont utilisé
l'avancée immédiate dans son périmètre
actuel concrètement vous ne faites une
seule déclaration comme d'ailleurs vous
le faisiez avant vous déclarez en gros
l'ombre d'heures et le salaire horaire
de votre employé
et le mois suivant
le CESU de ma page emploi prélève sur
votre compte le salaire enfin le reste à
charge en fait c'est à dire le salaire
moins le crédit d'impôts effectivement
c'est un système de tiers payant tout à
fait effectivement
pour venir justement sur la question du
calendrier tel qu'elle apparaît dans
l'article 5 alors on a bien à coeur
effectivement cette question de
l'équité de concurrence entre les
différents secteurs entre notamment
l'emploi direct et l'emploi intermédié
alors s'agissant quand même de
ce qui aujourd'hui dans le l'avance
médiate aujourd'hui
donc pour les ménages qui ne sont pas
bénéficiaires là pas la PCH on peut
bénéficier de l'avance immédiate qu'on
soit en emploi direct ou en emploi
intermédié alors le sujet est plus
compliqué effectivement mettre en oeuvre
pour les ménages qui bénissent la PCH
parce qu'il faut intégrer notamment les
services de gestion
des départements dans le dispositif or
on a des choix très variés entre les
départements dans la manière dont ils
ont des relations financières avec les
services
de la personne dire que un certain
nombre de départements notamment ont des
systèmes de convention avec les services
de la personne où il verse directement
les sommes et donc il faut reconstruise
autant le système et finalement assez
simple à mettre en place pour l'emploi
direct
et d'ailleurs on a commencé
l'expérimentation sur l'emploi direct
leur loi 60 personnes dedans donc ça
reste l'avantage concurrentiel il y a
pas davantage concurrentiel ou
distorsion de concurrence le sujet il
est plus complexe agissant effectivement
de l'emploi indirect et donc faut qu'on
travaille c'est pour du coup contrat
c'est vraiment ce qu'on va faire cet
automne très rapidement avec les
départements et le secteur nécessaire et
personne pour déterminer en fait le bon
circuit de gestion qui tiennent compte
du fait qu'il ne faut pas effectivement
demander d'avance des frais au ménages
qu'il faut
par ailleurs que les départements
puissent comme aujourd'hui vérifier le
service fait c'est comme une exigence
assez fort de leur part ce qu'on peut
comprendre parce qu'ils sont payeurs
et par ailleurs un circuit qui puisse
être mis en place dans un calendrier
proche de celui de l'emploi indirect
donc
[Musique]
on a déjà alors ce que l'article alors
je vous avoue que je n'ai plus en tête
je crois qu'il y en ajustement du
calendrier mais quand même qui reste
bien dans l'idée de
d'avoir un 15 et très proche entre les
deux secteurs
et après dans l'article il y a d'autres
dispositions par exemple sur le compte
les contrôles réalisés par l'URSSAF sur
les organismes de la personne pour
qu'ils puissent rentrer dans le
dispositif voilà le l'article ne part
pas seulement son calendrier et d'autres
aspects plutôt techniques mais qui sont
dans ce dans cet article mais en tout
cas l'intention est bien effectivement
d'avoir une équité entre entre le entre
les deux secteurs
alors concernant la question posée par
le dessinateur mouillé sur les les
organismes vaginales en zone de
radiation rurale alors
j'avoue il faut que je vérifie ce point
parce que j'ai en tête de manière
générale l'application
d'un certain nombre d'exonération de
cotisations sociales
aux organismes statuts publics et
souvent comme un point qui est parfois
un point de difficulté clairement
d'application du droit donc il faut que
je vérifie ce point je vous apporterai
si vous en êtes d'accord la réponse
après après cette audition
alors concernant la question posée par
Monsieur le Sénateur Jassin sur les
médecins retraité alors je vais revenir
justement sur ce dispositif qui a été
mis en place il y a maintenant deux ans
du régime simplifié des professions
médicales
alors ça vise à répondre au fait que au
de la même la question des médecins
retraités
l'exercice
libéral classique peut être très
dissuasif en termes de cotisations
sociales pour quelqu'un qui a une petite
activité libérale
il faut que je sois vigilant autant
excusez-moi pardon
alors d'accord alors
j’explique pourquoi ça peut être assez
pénalisant l'exercice libéral classique
pour quelqu'un qu'une activité libérale
réduite c'est d'une part vous devez
faire une comptabilité précise de vos
produits et de vos charges
vous êtes sur un système où vous cotisez
manières avec les thèmes d'acompte et de
régularisation en n + 1
et donc par ailleurs vous avez les
cotisations des caisses de retraite des
professions de santé qui pour certaines
finalement prévoit des cotisations
forfaitaire que vous soit votre revenu
et donc si vous avez une activité
réduite c'est extrêmement lourd de tenir
vous êtes comptabilité le fait d'avoir
des décalages entre acompte
régularisation
c'est un sens si vous avez une activité
classique et permanente assez stable ce
qui est le cas des provisions de santé
en général mais si c'est une activité
plus limitée ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
approprié et par ailleurs effectivement
le niveau des cotisations forfaitaire
peut être totalement dissuasif si vous
n'expliquerez et donc c'est pour ça que
ce régime simplifié a été mis en place
il y a deux ans
en fait ce régime il est complètement
inspiré j'irais de l'auto-entreprise je
rappelle l'auto-entreprise n'est pas
possible pour l'exercice d'une activité
de soins
alors pour toute une série de raisons
mais notamment parce que il s'agissait
d'éviter que on puisse avoir une
distorsion entre les professionnels qui
seraient dans les caisses de classiques
de retraite des projets de santé et les
autres entrepreneurs mais ce dispositif
serait régime simplifié il est vraiment
inspiré l'auto-entreprise c'est-à-dire
que vous cotisez sur votre chiffre
d'affaires vous n'avez pas à tenir la
comptabilité de vos charges vous
déclarez vous payez le mois ou le
trimestre suivant donc à base décalage
entre les revenus et les cotisations et
c'est strictement proportionnel vous
payez une seule fois à l'URSSAF donc il
y a pas ce côté disproportionné parfois
des cotisations forfaitaire par rapport
à
l'activité et donc vous payez en une
seule fois à l'URSSAF et après l'URSSAF
reverse à la carpe ce qui lui revient
donc c'est un dispositif
qui a d'abord été conçu plutôt pour
notamment les internes qui commencent
avec une cité libérale réduite
ou les remplaçants
on a déjà se dit quelques retraités qui
qui l'utilisent
qui a trouvé alors même qu'on est dans
un contexte un peu particulier pour n'a
pas fait en promotion comme Catherine
son public c'est à dire en deux ans
seulement déjà 6500 professionnels qui
ont qui utilisent ce dispositif et donc
ce que prévoit l'article 9 c'est
l'étendre aux activités de régulation
donc mon texte qu'on sait de besoin de
régulation après si je puis me permettre
un commentaire je pense que le succès de
ce dispositif et par ailleurs la
question que vous posez montre bien
qu'il y a à mon sens besoin
d'un cadre
et on pourrait utiliser des petits en
fait en l'étendant d'un cadre pour
les activités uniquement libérales
réduites parce que en fait aujourd'hui
la loi tellement il y a une série de
conditions pour en bénéficier il faut
être soit remplaçant soit étudiant soit
demain régulateur il y a un chiffre
d'affaires un plafond chiffre d'affaires
qui est quand même assez bas dit ce 1000
euros et donc on fait 19000 euros de
chiffre d'affaires et finalement ça ce
que nous dise certains médecins qui
l'utilisent et qu'on y arrive assez vite
voilà et donc voilà je pense que dans un
contexte on a un besoin de professionnel
qui ont de retrouver du temps médical
tout simplement voilà il serait
intéressant je pense de de voir comment
on peut à l'avenir
étendre ce dispositif le le libéralisé
en quelque sorte alors ça suppose de
tenir compte des questions d'équilibre
avec lesquelles de retraite des poissons
de santé
mais voilà je trouve que ça intéressant
pour des personnes qui veulent avoir une
activité libérale partielle voilà je
pense que dès que vous avez à 100%
libérale n'a pas de sens mais qu'on soit
sur un retraité qui veut reprendre ou
maintenir une petite activité libérale
toujours par semaine sur le cas du de
l'interne qui fait quelques
remplacements ou même de médecin salarié
qui
veut faire un peu de libérer à côté ça
peut être un dispositif intéressant
voilà donc je saisissais cette occasion
d'en faire la promotion
et donc de voir comment dans l'avenir on
peut les temps y compris d'ailleurs
peut-être d'autres professions de santé
madame la fenêtre sur les problèmes
informatiques concernant les
travailleurs indépendants notamment si
je comprends bien alors c'est un sujet
sur lequel on a quand même beaucoup
travaillé ces dernières années avec le
RSI lorsqu'il existait et aujourd'hui
c'est à dire qu'il y a eu comme
énormément d'investissement pour
résoudre les difficultés informatiques
rencontrées et d'ailleurs si on se place
avant la crise sanitaire ça s'était
traduit très visiblement dans la
satisfaction des indépendances
c'est-à-dire qu'on avait un niveau de
paiement qui s'était très fortement
amélioré pour les intérieurs
indépendants et on sait qu'en général
lorsqu'il y avait une preuve du RSI les
problèmes très fort en 2008 ça s'est
traduit par une très forte dégradation
du paiement parce que les gens n'avaient
plus confiance dans ce qu'on leur
demandait on était revenu avant la crise
sanitaire à des niveaux de paiement
très très satisfaisant même meilleur que
ce qu'on avait avant on arrive
aujourd'hui à on a des niveaux d'appel
téléphonique qui sont tout à fait
normaux donc on dirait il n'y a pas de
problème je dis pas que ça n'arrive
jamais mais aujourd'hui on a retrouvé un
niveau de fonctionnement qui nous semble
satisfaisant je dirais dans les dans les
dans les préoccupations qu'on prend en
charge et non seulement le bon calcul
des cotisations leur encaissement mais
derrière l'établissement des droits
notamment des droits retraite pour les
indépendants et donc aujourd'hui c'est
que c'est un sujet qui a très mal
fonctionné il y a 15 ans et pendant
plusieurs années mais aujourd'hui
la
CNAV dispose des données pour calculer
la retraite des travailleurs
indépendants donc aujourd'hui ce système
fonctionne mieux alors ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il n'y a pas des sujets qui
peuvent être une difficulté on sait par
exemple les questions pour les
micro-entrepreneurs qui relèvent de la
CIPAV et ça renvoie aussi à des
questions juridiques des contentieux qui
sont qui ont eu lieu sur le calcul de
leur cotisations on sait aussi que il y
a un centre de situation notamment va
travailler indépendant ou ils n'ont pas
forcément payé régulièrement leur
cotisations
et ces moments de la retraite qui se
rend compte que ils n'ont pas tous leurs
droits parce que pour les indépendants
c'est sur les cotisations payées qui
permettent d'établir d'établir les
droits et puis on sait aussi par
ailleurs qu'on a nous à la situation
réglée par exemple à Mayotte ou
aujourd'hui on n'a pas repris une
collecte de la cotisation retraite pour
les indépendants donc il y a encore
quelques petites situations qui sont
plus des situations très ciblées mais
globalement ça ça fonctionne aujourd'hui
ça fonctionne normalement
monsieur le rapporteur général je paye
pas retrouver
l'expirateur général excusez-moi
mes excuses
c'est tellement ancré dans mon
dans mon en fait je vous présente tous
mes excuses ah oui l'évaluation de la
faute j'arrive plus à me relire et donc
j'arrive plus à relire la question alors
nous sommes toujours
sur une évaluation de la fraude
pour dire cela fait maintenant plus de
10 ans désormais que nous réalisons des
évaluations de la fraude entendu comme
le traditionnel sur la base de contrôle
aléatoire comme ils ont tous les ans
c'est à dire tous les ans une partie des
contrôles
URSSAF contre la dissimulés sont des
contrôles aléatoires c'est-à-dire
établis sur des échantillons par le
staticien et visant uniquement à mesurer
la prévalence du travail dissimulé dans
un secteur donné
et donc c'est un travail qu'on fait
depuis des années et qui nous permet
d'avoir aujourd'hui elles sont assez
robustes de l'afro de cotisations
sociales
qu'on a partagé avec le Conseil national
de formation statistique donc voilà
aujourd'hui on est des évaluations de
l'ordre de cet à 8 milliards pour ce qui
concerne les salariés on a pu récemment
progresser aussi la fraude concernant
les travailleurs indépendants et
auto-entrepreneurs on est de l'ordre de
1 à 2 milliards de fraudes donc on pense
qu'on a un risque de trahis-mulé qui est
de on va dire entre 7 et 10 milliards
voilà
alors par rapport à cela l'an dernier on
a redressé 800 millions en termes de
lucrat dissimulé donc en gros on couvre
10% du risque alors s'agissant de fraude
il n'y a pas de monde vont couvre 100%
de fraude ça n'existe pas
n'empêche que on peut on doit faire plus
que les 10% qu'on fait aujourd'hui alors
je tiens à dire que on a eu une
progression quasi constante des montants
redressés si on compare la période
13-17 la période 18-22 on devrait avoir
fait plus 50% en termes de
montant redressé
et alors la question vous posez pour
l'avenir c'est une question qui sera
discuté dans le cas de la future
convention de suggestions entre l'URSSAF
et l'État
mais il est normal et prévisible que
l'État nous demande de continuer
progression du mémordre et alors ça va
reposer sur quoi ça va reposer à la fois
sur plus de moyens humains c'est-à-dire
nous avons eu au cours de cette période
un renforcement des des effectifs
consacrés à la lutte contre illégal donc
nous allons poursuivre ce renforcement
et puis ça repose aussi sur des outils
le tableau pour mieux cibler les
contrôles nous avons depuis deux ans un
outil de data mining qui permet en
croisant beaucoup de données de mieux
cibler nos contrôles en matière de le
prêt dissimulé avec des résultats
intéressants et toujours en termes
d'exploitation de données nous mettons
en place la semaine prochaine
une nouvelle base de données qui
centralisera les données sur les
détachements déclaration préalable de
détachement ce qui devrait nous
permettre de mieux croiser et de mieux
cibler nos contrôles sur la fraude de
détachement dont on sait que c'est un
enjeu très important en termes de
risques d'évasion sociale et aussi de
distorsion de concurrence pour les
entreprises françaises
et donc pour conclure donc la question
posée par la symétrie ce Jacques mais
alors effectivement
sur ces sujets la loi et est un peu
binaire c'est à dire que il y a toute
une série de situations où la loi
prévoit les conditions dans lesquelles
l'employeur peut verser peut prendre en
charge une aide etc
ce dispositif que vous mentionnez étant
nouveau je pense qu'il n'est pas listé
dans le pas la loi donc
sans changement de la loi je crains que
on doit effectivement considérer que
c'est soumis à cotisations
je vous remercie de votre attention
coucou Monsieur le Directeur et
que à une prochaine audition et
maintenant nous allons entendre la CNAF
merci au revoir monsieur